[MUSIC PLAYING]
PRAJAKTA JOSHI: So if
I had only two words
to sum up how we think about
security in Google Cloud,
it's this--
it would be trust nothing.
So as you start moving your
services to Google Cloud,
the first thing you do is,
obviously, secure your VPC.
You'd secure
connectivity to your VPC.
You'd apply really
granular policies with IM--
Kubernetes Engine Network
Policies, and more.
And one of the most
important things
that you will do after
this is to secure
your internet-facing apps.
Now, this is
actually a tough job,
because you do need to
serve your users fast.
But then at the same time,
you need to block out
DDoS and application attacks.
And this will be the
focus of our talk today.
So, how can you
defend your services
against a protocol,
volumetric, and then
application DDoS attacks?
So this is what it looks like.
Now, this is
actually a graph that
is drawn based on the
DDoS attacks on Google's
own services, so services
such as Search, and YouTube,
and Gmail.
And of course, our
security experts
work around the clock to
protect Google's own services
from these attacks.
And as you can see, the attacks
are growing exponentially
in volume, and not
just in this respect,
but also in respect
to packets per second
or any of the other parameters.
And you can notice that the
scale is already past 1.7 TBps.
So one of the things I did was
to ask our DDoS defense lead,
like, what does absorbing a
huge DDoS attack feel like?
And he says, absorbing
the large DDoS attack,
it requires the
bandwidth needed to watch
half a million YouTube
videos all at the same time
in high definition.
So that's what it feels like.
Now, if you look at this, these
are all of the Google services
and partner solutions that
you have at your disposal
to go defend against
all of these attacks.
The only one I'm not going
to cover in this talk
is the last one, which
is Project Shield.
But that is actually
our free service
that uses Google's technology
to protect new sites and then
freedom of expression from
the DDoS and other attacks.
So the first best
practice that we recommend
for your
internet-facing services
is to start with a global
load balancer and with TLS
everywhere.
So wherever possible, use TLS.
And then as it relates
to the load balancer,
you will use either our
HTTPS load balancer.
Or if your traffic is non-HTTP--
so let's say you're running
SMDB--
then you would actually run
the SSL proxy load balancer.
And both of these are, again,
global load balancing flavors,
which means you can put your
backends in any region you
want.
And you can front them
with a single VIP,
which gives you
also a single point
to apply all of your policies.
We also have several features
including SSL policies.
So you can restrict, for
instance, specific ciphers,
or you can restrict
certain TLS versions.
And this is especially
important for PCI compliance.
So we put in our global
HTTP/HTTPS load balancer.
We put in our policies.
The next thing that you
would want to layer in
is Cloud Armor.
Now, this is a new service
that we introduced recently.
And if you think of
what it provides,
you obviously need the
[? table ?] [? stakes ?] L3
and L4 DDoS defense, which is
actually really hard to defend
against.
In addition to that,
you need something
that's very extensible,
a way you can
express what your intent is.
So that is why there's a policy
framework and a rules language.
And then you have your features,
such as blacklist, whitelist.
Or maybe you want to
control access based on geo.
And then you have
your WAF protection.
And with all of
this, you obviously
want to know what's going on.
So there's the
telemetry aspect of it.
And with all of this, then you
can also layer in a product
that we call
identity-aware proxy.
So this is based on BeyondCorp,
which is how identities
handle inside Google.
And then if you layer all
of these three together,
one of the other things that
you will do is you have your VPC
or you have your
instances in your VPC.
And you would configure the
firewalls on those instances
to only allow traffic
through the load balancer,
because you put all of these
knobs at the load balancer.
And you want to ensure that no
other internet-facing traffic
actually leaks to your backends.
So let's talk a little
bit about Cloud Armor.
The first thing, as I
mentioned, is that it gives you
a policy framework.
What you can see here is a snip
of our GCloud console, Google
Console.
And then you can see the three
policies that exist in there.
If you start zooming
in on these policies,
the first thing is you can
apply a Cloud Armor policy
for a given backend service.
So let's say we've
got four services.
Maybe these are your four
internet-facing services.
You could choose to
use this policy--
let's say you've defined a
policy called Cloud Armor
Policy P1.
You could choose to use
it for Web-service 1.
You defined a policy, P2, and
you used it for your service
too.
And then you defined
a policy, P3,
but maybe it's applicable
to multiple services, so you
can reuse the same policy
for multiple services,
as you can see in there.
If you look closely at any
of those policies, what
you would notice is that
a policy can comprise
for a hierarchy of rules.
And then within
each rules, you have
something that you match
the traffic against.
And then there's
an action that you
take based on whether
there's a match or not.
So the actions could be allow
the traffic, deny the traffic.
We also have an interesting
option called Preview.
And what that does is
lets you test out rules.
So if you configure the
preview option there,
it would simply log the action
but actually not take it
on your traffic.
So if you're testing
all the rules,
that's probably what you would
start with to begin with.
Now, when we started talking
about building [INAUDIBLE]
almost a way to go
express the rules,
we thought about using a
variety of different tools.
Some are proprietary.
But then we decided to
use something that's not
just flexible, but also open.
And we settled on CEL, which
is short for Common Expression
Language.
If any of you have
used Firebase,
you've already used CEL.
So that is what it's used for,
expressing certain expressions.
And then once you specify the
rules using this language,
Cloud Armor will
then use these rules
to go orchestrate the underlying
global infrastructure.
And then obviously
that infrastructure
is going to allow or
block your service,
based on whatever it is you
have configured for the rule.
So what are the types of
things that you can actually
do with Cloud Armor?
The first thing
that you can do is
you can either allow or block
traffic for IPs or CIDRs.
And this could be either IPv4
addresses or CIDRs or IPv6
as well.
So we support both.
If you think of the
other types of things
that you might want to
do, a very common ask
is for customers to
be able to control
based on the geolocation.
So that is what you see in here.
And you can combine it with
IP addresses using operators
like and or not.
One of the other
popular things is,
how do we defend
ourselves against all
of these application attacks?
And so that is what you see
what the cross-site scripting
and the SQL injection defense.
This is where, again, you
can see the rules language
in action.
So there's a custom
rule that's crafted
where it's looking
for US, and then it's
looking for certain
things in the user-agent.
And then it's looking for
a certain type of cookie.
And then you could choose to
either deny or permit along
with this one.
And then the last
important thing
is once your traffic
is allowed or blocked,
it would go lock
this in Stackdriver.
And then it will tell you which
is the policy that it matched,
which is the rule.
So the priority is actually
the rule number and then what
was the action that was taken.
So once you have all
of this in place,
it is very easy to
allow or block traffic
based on your
unique requirements.
So I wanted to actually
give you a quick look
at what's under the hood.
The first one is actually
pretty straightforward,
where essentially
for the L3, L4,
you will turn on the
global DDoS defense.
In here, let's turn
on this defense,
because what I want to show you
is actually what's coming next.
The second thing is
let's go and launch
an SQL injection, or "sequel"
injection, as some of you
call it.
And in here, it's actually worse
than just bringing your service
down.
Because it will actually go and
also try to steal your data.
So I wanted to just walk you
through the backend of this
to show you what it looks like,
which is, let's go in here.
This is the actual UI here.
You would go to the [? stack ?]
called Network Security.
And then you can
see that we have
a bunch of different policies.
So these could have been
just rules in our policy.
Or they can be different
policies itself.
Let's look at the one
for SQL injection.
Now, if you see in here,
the most important one
is the one you see in
here, which is evaluate
preconfigured expression.
So you just need one rule,
and then under the hood,
it's going to look for 160
patterns to actually go
and then block the traffic
of a SQL injection.
The other policy that
I wanted to show you
is the one that I
showed you briefly
on screen, which is this one.
And then if you see in
here, the first rule-- so
let's go and try and edit that.
So if you look at this rule,
and I see if I can zoom in
so you can see it better.
So when we start looking at
our rules, we have two modes.
One of them is essentially
a basic mode, which
is the one you see on top.
And that's simply if you want to
add a blacklist or a whitelist.
What is most important is
actually this advanced mode,
which is what you see here.
And then the entire rules
language that you see actually
can be used here.
So this was the
specific example where
you would look for
traffic, which is from US,
and then whether user and
agent contains bad bot.
And then the request
headers, the cookie itself,
contains the specific value
that you see in there.
Some of the other things
I wanted to point out
is, as I mentioned,
there was an allow.
If you do a deny, you can also
look through several of these
and then figure out what is
the status quo that you want.
And then the Preview mode
you can simply enable here.
And then the priority would
tell its order or its place
inside the hierarchy.
So you can see that
on the right here.
So that was basically a look
at what the policies look like.
And then switching back to
Cloud Armor and then some
of the things that
we do with it,
one of the most interesting
things that you can actually
do with Cloud Armor
is to combine it
with several of
Google's technologies
and also combine it with several
of our partner solutions.
So while we won't
have enough time
to go through solutions
from each of these partners,
you can see that it ranges from
identity and access management
to scanning to
governance, compliance,
even we have like CASBs.
We've got things against
phishing and so on.
So on our website, we actually
describe each of these partner
solutions in great detail.
One of the partners I
specifically wanted to call out
is Reblaze.
And Reblaze provides a
web security solution.
So it's in use at eBay and
several of our other customers.
And then, of course,
it provides a WAF.
It will provide DDoS
protection, anti scraping.
It will provide
fine-grained ACLs.
One of the really interesting
bits about Reblaze is this--
that the architecture is
actually fully powered by GCP,
along with a lot of
value-added intelligence
that Reblaze brings
to the solution.
So I wanted to put
this here so you
can look at some of the
foundational building
blocks that come from GCP.
Specifically, there
are five services.
So there's global
load balancing.
There is CDN.
There is Cloud Armor.
There is BigQuery.
And there's machine learning.
Now, the global load
balancing provides
the Edge infrastructure to
absorb layer three and layer
four DDoS attacks.
And it also provides a
point to TLS termination.
Now, the BigQuery is combined
with machine learning.
And then the kinds
of things it will do
is like traffic analysis in real
time or application analysis.
So this is where you want to
[? profile ?] legitimate users,
their input, and then make sure
that it is something that you
can feed back into the WAF.
It'll do real-time
biometric data analysis.
So this is used to
tell, for instance,
bots apart from humans.
And any time once it
detects something,
it'll use the Cloud Armor
things, such as blacklist.
So your signatures, and
it'll delegate Cloud Armor
wherever applicable.
And then what the main
thing it'll give you
is essentially defense
of the Edge with this.
And then your traffic
or your back traffic
will never reach your VPC.
And then you've got the
Reblaze proxy instances, which
will run all of
the Reblaze value
added features that wouldn't
get delegated to any
of these systems.
So the reason I
wanted to show you
this is because this
shows what is possible
using several of
Google's technologies,
especially Global LB,
Cloud Armor, other GCP
services, to harden your own
posture for your own services.
And then, of course,
you can complement
each of these with
solutions from our partners.
So this was a whirlwind
tour of Cloud Armor.
And I know we spoke
about partners.
One of the other things I wanted
to talk about is our customers.
And I think most of you are
aware that we announced Target
as our customer
at this GCP Next.
And with that, I'm
delighted to invite
Nick, our lead
engineer for Target,
to come and describe how
to think about application
security at Target.
Nick?
[APPLAUSE]
NICK JACQUES: Thank you.
Thanks, Prajakta.
Hi.
So my name's Nick Jacques.
I'm a lead engineer at Target
on our Cloud Platform team.
Just to give you a little
context around who I am
and what Target is, so Target's
a pretty popular US retailer.
We have over 1,800
stores in the US.
We also have a good amount
of distribution centers
and several
headquarters locations
and a handful of data centers.
I've been working on
our cloud platform team
for about three
years now, and I want
to provide a little
context around timelines.
Last year, the very, very
beginning of 2017, we
kind of embarked on this
journey to migrate our workloads
from a variety of cloud
providers into GCP.
We were able to do
that prior to what
we call peak season in 2017,
so before fall comes around
and Black Friday and
all kinds of fun times
around the holidays.
And things went really well.
So at the beginning of
2018, we thought, well,
we've migrated the
non-commerce parts of our site,
so the parts of the site that
will help you search or browse
to find a product or will
display product images
or reviews for you.
What about the
commerce part, the part
that accepts credit card
numbers, the part that
lets you check out on the site,
all kinds of things like that?
And we thought, this is
something we should do too.
Our commerce environment
was hosted in a dedicated
[? colo ?] facility.
And so we thought it was
time to modernize that.
So at the beginning
of 2018, around March,
we embarked on that journey.
And we're actually almost
entirely done with it.
So the vast part of
target.com, our mobile apps,
and a good piece of our APIs
as well have backends in GCP.
So moving on, let's
just kind of do
a little overview of Target's
architectural patterns.
So the way that we've
kind of built things out
is that we basically have a
CDN that fronts everything
that we have on the web.
So all of our traffic
comes through the CDN.
We apply a variety
of useful features
that the CDN provides,
things like caching, web app
firewalls, a massive
amount of logging.
And it also provides us
with some defense tactics.
So there we can
do rate limiting,
and we can also blacklist.
So if we're seeing
malicious traffic
or if we're receiving
large volumes of traffic,
we can handle it there.
The CDN is also useful
for us because Target
has a multi-cloud strategy.
So we have a pretty
big footprint in GCP,
but we don't want to paint
ourselves into the corner.
And so we want the ability to
use other CSPs or, for example,
if we have a trusted third
party provider for pieces
of our site or
certain functionality,
we want to be able to direct
that traffic to them as needed.
And then finally, the third
piece in this architecture
is using the L7 load balancer.
So I had a previous talk
just a few hours ago,
where we went into a really
deep dive about Target's
architecture in GCP.
Unfortunately, no one offers
time travel as a service
yet, so we can't go back.
But it will be
posted on YouTube.
So if you want a really deep
dive into Target's architecture
and how we're using a lot of the
network functionality of GCP,
I would encourage you
to check that out.
And in there,
you'll hear me just
gush about all
the amazing things
that these low balancers do.
We don't have to worry
about prewarming or scaling.
We don't have to worry about
regionalized load balancers,
and then doing
geolocation at the Edge
and trying to figure out
which load balancer is closest
to the user, things like that.
So it works really great for us.
One of the amazing things about
this that our teams really
enjoy is the ability
to scale based
on requests per second coming
in through the load balancer.
So this is especially great
if you have services that,
for example, don't hit the CPU.
So you can't really
auto scale based on CPU.
But you know that a
given instance can only
handle so much traffic,
so you can scale out
horizontally the
more requests are
coming into your load balancer.
So let's move past
that just a little bit.
And now we're going to start
talking about Cloud Armor.
So a really important
thing for Target
is that security
is for everyone.
It's for our team members.
It's for our guests.
It's for our team members
who are our guests.
It's for everyone
that we interact with.
So no matter what you're
doing on target.com,
or on the mobile
apps, or even using
our APIs at api.target.com,
security is really important.
And this is where Cloud Armor
starts to come into play.
So something was missing
for us last year.
Cloud Armor wasn't
generally available yet,
and so we were kind of
sitting there thinking,
hey, these load balancers,
these all seven load balancers,
are really great, but
something's missing.
We can't apply
firewall rules to them.
So that means that we don't
have a way to only allow traffic
from our CDN, for instance.
We didn't really have a good
method of ingress control.
And like anything you
put out on the internet,
we began to see some kind
of suspicious traffic.
You know, obviously
some of it's benign.
It's people just kind of
port knocking and seeing
what's going on out there.
Some of it, not so much.
So here you can see
just a quick snip
from Stackdriver logs of
traffic that is denied--
a lot of attempts to try
to get after phpMyADmin.
I took a little time, and I
tried to catalog some of these.
And now, this isn't a definitive
list or anything like this,
but obviously we saw quite
a bit of different attempts
to see if we had
phpMyAdmin, or WebDAV,
or even Drupal installed.
And so luckily, none
of this is actually
making it to our instances.
And our instances don't run
these pieces of applications.
But this still
isn't stuff that we
want coming into our
instances in the first place.
We don't want people
knocking on our door,
seeing what's going on there.
So this kind of moves into
knowing and understanding
traffic patterns.
Obviously there's a
pretty wide spectrum.
In some cases, in
some industries,
you can classify things
as known good based
on user interactions, or source
addresses, or things like that.
And in some cases, you can
classify things as known
bad, again, based on
sources or maybe you
set a cookie or
something like that.
And for a lot of
industries, there
is a pretty wide, gray
unknown in the middle.
In Target's case, luckily,
we actually kind of fall over
on the left hand side.
And the reason for that is
we have a pretty limited list
of criteria of what
is good traffic to us.
That is traffic coming
from our CDN provider.
That is traffic from our
headquarters and data centers.
It's traffic from
other GCP projects that
is egressing and hitting
api.target.com, for instance,
and some trusted third parties.
And then literally everything
else, we don't want.
So we don't want the
internet to come knocking.
We don't want adventurous
and crafty people trying
to figure out what
sales we're doing ahead
of time, things like that.
So this is where Cloud
Armor comes into play.
So just to give you kind
of a graphic view of this,
this is kind of our
overall architecture.
So we have the ability for
Target guests, and even people
who aren't guests or
applications and computers who
aren't guests, to access our
services through the CDN Edge.
And that will eventually
make its way through and then
come into our load balancers.
Now, what we don't
want to have happen
is this other traffic kind
of coming in from the side
and going through or bypassing
the architecture that we've
so carefully set up.
So what's really useful in
this particular instance
is basically applying Cloud
Armor just at the load balancer
there.
And so when this traffic
tries to come through again,
Cloud Armor just goes ahead
and blocks that for us.
So eventually, all the good
traffic will come through.
It will hit the instances or
our Kubernetes pods as intended.
And those backends will never
see that traffic that we just
don't want coming through.
So once we start talking
about using Cloud Armor,
something that's
really important
is how you actually are
going to use your policies.
We actually have two
different environments,
as I mentioned earlier--
our non-commerce environment
and our commerce environment.
And they're laid out a
little bit differently.
So our non-commerce
environments,
they're basically large,
monolithic projects
that are multitenant.
So we have many
different applications
running in these projects.
The advantage in
a single project
is you can deploy one
Cloud Armor security policy
and have that apply to all
of your Edge load balancers.
So for your deployments that
have many load balancers,
this is really advantageous,
because you basically
have centralized management
of those security policies.
Or if you have
special requirements
for a certain few
load balancers,
you can create one-off policies
and apply those as well.
If you have multiple
projects-- and this
is our case in our
commerce environment,
because we're using a
feature called shared VPC.
So in this type of
configuration, what happens is
we have multiple
projects that contain
just the applications
that are intended
for that particular project.
And those are bound to their
own individual subnets.
Each project and each
application in those projects
has their own load balancers.
And so we need to
distribute those policies
to each one of those
service projects
and then bind them to
the load balancers.
So that means things are
a little more distributed.
And it could be a little more
difficult for you to manage.
Luckily for us, things
work pretty well.
We have a centralized
Terraform repository
that contains all of
our Cloud Armor rules.
And so we're able
to deploy those
across our suite of service
projects pretty quickly.
So just to go
through a blueprint
of how we're doing things.
In our non-commerce
environment, we essentially
have a single policy for
all of our load balancers.
That policy is effectively
what I had just
mentioned a few slides ago.
We use terraform to
centrally manage that policy.
And our application teams and
our platform services teams
use an open source tool called
Spinnaker to create and manage
their load balancers and
also to deploy instances.
We currently have an
out-of-band process
that goes through and attaches
security policies to those load
balancers created
through Spinnaker.
In our commerce environment,
things are a little different.
We're much more aggressive
about the security policy
there-- or posture, obviously.
So what we do is we have a
policy per service project.
And that will attach
to the load balancers
in that given the
service project.
Again, we use Terraform
to manage these policies.
And what we do is we actually
abstract these policies
from our tenants.
So when our tenants use
Terraform to create their load
balancers, what's
actually happening
is there's a Terraform module
under the hood that contains
the Cloud Armor policies,
and it attaches it
to the load balancer.
So effectively, when we have
one of our application teams
create a load balancer
through Terraform,
the Cloud Armor security
policy and SSL policies
are automatically
applied like day one.
So there is never a concern
about a load balancer
that wouldn't have
these policies in place.
So then just to kind of
wrap things up there,
with our load balancers, we take
all of the Stackdriver logs,
including all of the Cloud
Armor logs, and what we do
is we use logging syncs to bring
those back to our data center.
Once in our data center, they
go through a series of Kafka
topics and subscriptions.
And we ingest them into Target's
security infrastructure.
So using that and looking at
the type of traffic that's
being blocked by Cloud
Armor, we can actually
gain some insights into
the type of traffic that's
happening there and detect
any possible attacks
that someone may be launching.
So if we rewind to our cloud
journey in GCP, in fall 2017,
Cloud Armor was in its
pretty early stages.
But we wanted to have
a defense mechanism
should anything occur.
So again, we were
ingesting logs.
And our security operations team
was basically analyzing those
and would tell us
real time if we needed
to take any sort of action.
Our Cloud Armor policy at the
time was tactical blacklisting.
So by that what I mean
is we had a rule set
that basically was
written to allow traffic
and then left space
in the middle that
specifically denies
particular traffic
from particular sources.
And then the default
rule is allow.
So in this way,
we've given ourselves
room to create
deny rules, but we
aren't going to stumble
and accidentally blacklist
one of our own addresses
and cause big problems.
One of the interesting
pieces about this--
because Cloud
Armor was in alpha,
we had a few folks that were
a little concerned at Target
about how this would operate.
Would it scale?
And our Google partners
mentioned to us
that this is used
at the Google Edge
for a lot of their products.
And so that helped out,
but there was still
a little bit of concern.
And so what we did is we
actually applied this policy
to all of our endpoints.
And we didn't tell any
of our application teams
that we did that.
And no one noticed
a single thing,
and everything went
off without a hitch.
So that was the kind of
proof in the pudding for us
that Cloud Armor
really does work.
When we talk about how we're
using Cloud Armor today,
we're shifting to a tactical
whitelisting approach.
So by that what I mean is, we
have several rules in place
that allow all of the
authorized traffic
that I mentioned earlier--
traffic from our CDNs, and data
centers, and things like that.
And then right
down at the bottom,
we deny everything else.
So in doing this, we
really restrict that
to those approved endpoints
and through the architecture
that we've so carefully set up
with WAF and caching and all
those great things
at the front end.
So we have these security
policies deployed to almost all
of our load balancers today.
And we have just a few that we
need to flip from Preview Mode
to Enable Mode and
block that traffic.
So just another tip of the
hat to the Preview Mode
feature of Cloud Armor,
it's worked really great,
and it's helped our application
teams identify, in some cases,
traffic from some of our systems
that they didn't even know
was hitting those endpoints.
So it's been really great to
help understand traffic there.
Just to go through quickly
some lessons that we learned--
obviously defense
in depth is a thing.
So adding Cloud
Armor isn't going
to fix everyone's problems.
You obviously need to
take quite a few steps,
but it does help in
terms of filtering out
some of the general traffic
out there on the internet.
We learned a very important
architectural anti-pattern,
and that is
egress/ingress hairpins.
So in our environments at
GCP, we operate in NATs.
So most of our instances don't
have external IP addresses.
And in some cases, we reach
out to parts of api.target.com
that also live inside GCP.
So we have this really nice
kind of hairpin going on.
And that can make it difficult
to write a Cloud Armor
policy, especially if you're
using items that auto scale,
and so you don't have
predictable IP addresses.
So that's something
that we learned
and something that
might be good to avoid.
Another item, which we're
working through right now,
is retroactively
applying policy.
It turns out if you start
really restricted and then open
things up a little bit,
people are happy with that.
If it turns out that if you
start with things fairly open
and then try to restrict
that, sometimes people
aren't a big fan of that.
So starting secure
by default in day one
is a really great thing
to do, rather than trying
to apply that over time.
Finally, just as kind of
a last few points here,
organizational inertia
can be hard to overcome.
So this kind of, again, goes
towards that retroactively
applying policies point.
So in every company
and every business,
it's a little bit
different, but sometimes can
be a little tricky.
And then there are
a few scenarios
that we've encountered that
don't quite perfectly work
for us, and we're still
researching and trying
to think of good solutions for.
The biggest one for us is our
users with split tunnel VPNs.
So when you're working
from the road or at home,
your laptop will
connect to Target
and send traffic intended
for Target's internal items
or internal endpoints
over the VPN.
When you are going towards
one of these public endpoints
or one of these
external endpoints,
it will not go over the VPN.
You won't have a Target IP
address, so you'll be blocked.
So we're still working
through some of those pieces
and working to make that a
little more predictable so
that those users can still get
their jobs done while they're
working from home or elsewhere.
So as we look towards
the future and things
that we're excited about--
pretty much everything
Prajakta just said.
We're looking forward
to a lot of things.
And one of the most
important pieces
that we're looking
forward to is the ability
to automate policy enforcement.
So if someone creates
a load balancer
in our non-commerce
environment, that Forseti
or perhaps another tool will
pick that up immediately
and attach a policy to it, so we
don't have to worry about that.
So with all that said,
I'll turn it over
to [? Sila ?]
who's going to talk
through quite a few interesting
new pieces of Cloud Armor.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER: Hello, good afternoon.
So far Prajakta and Nick talked
about protecting your cloud
services using Cloud Armor
for known predicted attacks.
You can use IP
whitelist/blacklist
to block or allow some traffic.
And you can also create
geo-based access tools,
geo-based access control
rules, as well as
SQL injection,
protection as well as
[? access ?] protection.
And taking one more
step with Cloud Armor,
you could also
create custom rules
to prevent attacks
from, let us say,
known hackers or known attacks.
But what about the protection
for the kind of attacks
that you did not anticipate?
Globally, attack volumes
are growing multiple times.
And there is also an
ever-increasing risk
of high volume attacks from
large amounts of small bots
as well as large,
powerful hosts.
So let's talk about some
of the existing strategies
your network security
engineers will
apply for protecting
against these large attacks.
Number one, you could
increase your serving capacity
to multiple times.
But some of these attacks are
so big no reasonable increase
in capacity will
actually protect you
against these attacks.
And you could set
volume thresholds.
But the problem with
the volume thresholds
is that when the attack is
four times, five times bigger
than your baseline
volume, then you
are allowing more attack traffic
than the genuine traffic.
And thirdly, you can set
up analysis of the logs,
as well as set up some
statistical algorithms
to run through the logs
and come up with rules.
But the problem is, by the
time you react to this attack
and come up with a
rule that will isolate
the attacked
traffic, your service
may already experience downtime.
Want if a system exists such
that some of these attacks
can be detected automatically?
And such a system can
also detect and isolate
the signatures of these attacks
and come up with rules for you
to block or throttle
the traffic.
And let me introduce
Cloud Armor AI.
At Cloud Armor, we are
leveraging Google's innovation
and deep learning as well as AI
to come up with a DDoS attack
protection system that
will not only detect
but will also provide
protection in a timely manner.
So you have seen the
demo of Cloud Armor
a few minutes, Prajakta
demonstrated to you how
to write the rules and how
you can apply them and protect
your system.
So today, as it is, Cloud
Armor will protect you
against SQL injection as
well as [? access ?] threats,
and you can write
your own custom tools
for some of the known
attacks that you
have faced in the past.
And you can do IP
whitelist/blacklist
for allowing or
blocking the traffic.
So let us say a hacker planned
an attack on your system
and that falls into the
existing spectrum of the rules
that you've already created.
Cloud Armor will effectively
block all this traffic.
Your systems are healthy.
And life is good and no
blaring pagers, right?
Here comes a quickly
ramping up bot attack.
And the way this bot
attack is structured
is that it rotates through
multiple user agents
a set of multiple
user agents as well
as referral URLs and coming
from one or two IP addresses.
And this attack will quickly
overwhelm your services
if the volume is big.
And your pagers will go off.
And what would be the strategy
of your network engineers here?
They will have to
go through the logs,
and they will have to set
up a statistical analysis
to go sift through
the logs, come up
with isolating the signature.
You may have spent any
time between an hour
to several hours, and your
service will most probably
experience some downtime.
With Cloud Armor AI, most
of this toil can be avoided.
Cloud Armor leverages deep,
neural networks' architectures
to detect the attack and
isolate the signature,
as well as come up with rules
for you to block the attack.
In general, deep neural
networks are already efficient.
They allow us to
predict these attacks
with a lot more accuracy
than regular machine-learning
algorithms.
And they also allow us to
fast train our attack models,
and we will also be
able to do distributed
training of these
attacks, attack models,
with large data sets.
Once Cloud Armor AI isolates
the signature of the attack,
it will also generate
an alarm and it'll also
create Cloud Armor rule
for you to apply and block
or throttle the traffic.
And once your network
service engineers
receive the alert for
the ongoing attack,
they can actually go to
Cloud Armor's attack console
and check the signature, check
the rule, and apply the rule.
So from the time
you apply the rule,
it may take a few minutes for
it to propagate, the policy
to be propagated to all
of the load balancers.
But from that attack
to the defense,
it may take few minutes from
the time the attack ramps up.
The advantages
with this system is
that you don't have to
set up service thresholds.
And it's basically,
you don't have
to worry about your
periodic traffic variations.
Cloud Armor AI will train
based on your traffic model
and also the traffic patterns.
And it will ignore
any periodic patterns
that your service
may experience.
For example, you may
experience peaks in the morning
and in the evening.
And those will be ignored and
will not be flagged as attacks.
It's basically designed
to reduce the toil.
And as you see, Cloud
Armor AI is not one thing.
It's basically
the whole pipeline
weaves through a multiple
machine-learning algorithms
and provides you the protection
as well as a quick detection
of the attacks.
Let's do a demo
of Cloud Armor AI.
Here is Cloud
Armor AI's console.
And this is the traffic
analysis console.
As you see here, your
services is fine.
You have a baseline
around 5,000 QPS.
And the top part shows
you the attack traffic.
And currently, there are no
attacks, so everything is good.
And on the top, as you
see here, the console
shows you the total
cumulative request
as well as the allowed request.
And it chose the blocked
and predicted request.
And here is your
defense console.
So far, systems are normal.
Everything is good.
Now let's initiate an attack.
So we've talked about
the attack previously.
It basically weaves through
a lot of user agents
as well as referral URLs.
And let's launch the
attack on the service.
And let's see what happens
and if Cloud Armor AI
will detect the attack or not.
So once you launch the
attack, let's go back
to our traffic analysis tool.
And as you see here,
you see towards the end
there is a peak in the
volume, but Cloud Armor AI
hasn't detected yet.
So you it may take any
time between 30 seconds
to two minutes
for Cloud Armor AI
to pick up that there
is an attack going.
So as you see here, the
attack volume is ramping up.
And it's going to
6,500 QPS or so.
And it's slowly ramping
up to 9,000 and 14,000.
And there you see Cloud Armor
detecting an attack here.
It's not only detecting
that there is an attack,
but it also gives
you a classification
of what part of your
traffic is attack
and what is actually
a genuine traffic.
And as you see on the
top, here on the top,
you will see the
predicted attacks.
Now we can click on the spike
over on the predicted attacks,
and we can actually see
what is the characteristics
of this attack.
As you see here--
so you have the attack
coming through IP addresses.
50% of the attack is distributed
to one IP and the other.
And you have referral
values basically taking up
some of the volume.
And it's not only
the referral values.
One of the primary
characteristics of this attack
is also a user agent.
So it will assign
what kind of volume
is coming from
each one of these.
So the advantage
of Cloud Armor AI
is not just detecting the peak.
Any statistical algorithm will
be able to detect the peak.
But here, you are able to
detect that this is an attack,
and you are able to
characterize the attack
and come up with a rule.
And here is your console,
the defense console.
You can see that the
service is under attack.
And also the attack
signature, it
shows you what are the prominent
features of this attack.
And here we have the
remote host, user agent,
and the referral URLs.
And it also suggests a rule.
So you've pretty much reduced
your attack response time
from hours to minutes here.
And then once you see the
rule, you review the rule,
you can go ahead and click
on the rule to apply.
And it may take a few minutes
for the load balancers
to apply the policy.
So that concludes our
Cloud Armor AI demo.
So back in September
2016, Evernote
announced that they
are migrating their
on prem to Google Cloud.
And post the completion,
they have given us
a really big endorsement, saying
that they not only matched
the on prem security
with GCP, but they
were able to surpass
the security levels they
experienced on prem.
So this is a great
endorsement for us.
And it's not only
Evernote, but there
are several other
customers using Cloud Armor
to secure their deployments.
And our goal today here
is to share with you some
of those awesome
customer experiences
as well as demonstrate that
GCP is a secure first network.
We are investing a lot into
making your services secure.
And with Cloud Armor
and Cloud Armor AI,
you can not only secure
your GCP services
but also reduce the toil in
protecting your services.
And basically, by
using Cloud Armor AI,
you are outsmarting
your attackers.
[MUSIC PLAYING]